[Music]
foreign
era has been developed we have a lot of
pollution that has been generated the
highest rate of deaths on Earth is due
to pollution about 9.2 million per year
and it is very important not only to do
the research but also to develop the new
generation of scientists that they will
lead the field so how we can eliminate
the risks
to exposure to chemicals from the
environment is how we can improve the
well-being of humans
[Music]
we have the the center on climate
changes and health they're doing a lot
of a lot of work in terms of studying
the changes of the temperature and what
are the effects on mental health and
also how the changes of the climates
affect the ecosystem and also the
wildfires has a major effect because
they create a lot of particulate matter
and a lot of pollution that could affect
the human health so it's a very
important issue which again it has a
major implication into the changes in
human health
[Music]
we're exposed to multiple factors every
day which can really cause disease to
one of our faculty has developed a very
novel method by which you can monitor
every individual to what they have been
exposed to and then you can determine
what is the exposure what is the health
effects on that we also have faculty who
is the father of the clean chemistry in
other words how we can make a new world
helping to develop sustainable chemicals
that you can use them that will not have
an impact on you know on human health
[Music]
1.4 dioxane which is a stabilizer of
several organic solvents that make and
cause cancer this chemical it's a water
contaminant can go to the soil from all
the exposures and then it can get up to
your drinking water it's very difficult
to be filtered this super fund is trying
to study the mechanism by which this
chemical can cause liver cancer the
other important thing about the center
is it's one of the few projects
throughout Yale that brings Fourier
schools together I'm a big fan of
collaboration I think this is the
uniqueness of our department so we're
very good in connecting the department
and not only with the other departments
within the School of Public Health but
also with other schools or Gail and then
also we collaborate with State agencies
with the community so it's very
important not only for our department or
faculty to be in touch with them but
also to pass this kind of mentality to
our students how a scientists how we do
the community engagement how we listen
to the community that tell us what are
their concerns and director of research
towards that
[Music]